we're told ahmad is going to walk 20
kilometers for a charity fundraiser
and the first part of this question they
say write an equation that represents
how many hours t
the walk will take if a mod walks at a
constant rate of r kilometers per hour
pause the video and see if you can have
a go at that
all right now let's work through this
together
so you might be familiar with the notion
that distance is equal to rate times
time
for example if you were to walk at a
rate of five kilometers per hour
for
two hours you would say five times two
five kilometers per hour times two hours
would give you 10 kilometers
now in this situation they've given us
the number of kilometers or the distance
in this situation so in this situation d
is equal to 20. so 20 is going to be
equal to our rate which we are told is
going to be our kilometers per hour
times our time
which is t hours
now they're writing they're asking us
for an equation that represents how many
hours the walk will take if a mod walks
at a constant rate of r so the way that
it's phrased it sounds like they want us
to solve for t where t is going to be
equal to some expression here that deals
with r and probably some other things so
if we put in any r here then we can get
the time so if we know what the rate is
if you put that in here because it's
already solved for t we'll be able to
solve for that time you could think of r
as the independent variable that you
could try different values out for and
that t is the dependent variable it's
the thing that we have solved for
so let's do that let's rewrite this
expression here by solving for t
and i could do it right over here if i
have 20 is equal to rt if i want to
solve 4t what can i do
well i could divide both sides by r
if i do that on the right hand side that
i'm just left with a t here because an r
divided by r is just 1 and on the left i
have 20 over r so i have t
is equal to 20
over
r and we're done this will tell us how
many hours
a mod will take to walk
based on the rate you give me a rate i'm
just going to divide 20 by that and i'm
going to give you t
you might say why is this useful well
this is useful because now that we have
it written this way any time someone
gives an r to you you just take 20
divided by that and it essentially is
already going to solve for what your
time is how far how long ahmad's going
to have to walk
question two how many hours will the
walk take if a moth walks at a constant
rate of six kilometers per hour
well here is an example of that where
they are giving us the actual rate and
they want the time so we just take the 6
and replace it in for r so we get t is
equal to 20
over 6 which is
3 and a third hours which would be the
same thing as 3 hours and 20 minutes
depending on how you want to view it
let's do another example here
so here we're told at the end of each
day a restaurant makes soup with
whatever amount of vegetable stock is
unused that day let me center this a
little bit
the soup recipe calls for 400
milliliters of water for every 500
milliliters of vegetable stock
write an equation that represents how
much water the restaurant should use and
we'll use the variable w with any amount
of vegetable stock b
all right and then we'll do part two
right after that
so let's look at this 400 milliliters of
water for every 500 milliliters of
vegetable stock and so to get my head
around this i like just to think about
let's put a little table here and so you
could say amount of water let me write
it this way
water
and vegetable stock
vegetable stock
so
for every 500 milliliters of vegetable
stocks if you had 500 milliliters of
vegetable stock and i won't write the
milliliters then you're going to have
400 milliliters of water
if you had a thousand here which is two
times that well you're going to have
twice as much water which is going to be
800
and so you can see this relationship
that's forming no matter what the
vegetable stock is if you essentially
take four four-fifths of that that is
the amount of water you take four-fifths
that is the amount of water so if you
had only five milliliters of vegetable
stock you take four-fifths you get the
amount of water so another way to think
about it is the water at that you need
to use is going to be four-fifths of the
amount of vegetable stock that you are
going to be using
and so
actually we just did part one we wrote
an equation that represents how much
water the restaurant should use with any
amount of vegetable stock and the way
that they phrased it we're solving for w
given some v that you might have and
since we're solving for w here we would
consider w the dependent variable and v
is the independent variable you can give
me different v's and then i can put that
into this little equation here and i can
solve for the w so we've done the first
part
if there are 800 milliliters of unused
vegetable stock
how much water should the restaurant use
to make soup
well we can just take this 800 and
substitute it in 4v to figure that out
in this situation the amount of water to
use is four
fists
times 800
and that's going to be let's see 800
divided by
5 100 divided by 5
is 20 and so and you're gonna have eight
of those so it's 160 so 160 times 4
is equal to
640 milliliters
and we are done